santander showed bunt and took a ball on
the first pitch
flynn ready
hit well down the right field line
short hops against the wall
and anthony santander continues to swing
a hot bat he's on second with a stand-up
double
back toward the middle gosselin gets to
it throws off balance and it's in time
what a play
how about that release tom it's one
thing to get to it but the release
having it was in and out of his glove no
he's got to rush it with iglesias
running
that is uh making it easy
back to the box effland's got it
it's gonna turn out to be an easy
comfortable inning for zach just seven
pitches two on two down no score orioles
second inning
and a strike three call that was on the
inner part of the plate
somebody's getting a little mouthy down
on the field
ramon dejesus got the helmet off
four strikeouts ref one through two we
go to the bottom of the second
here's andrew andrew hitting 500 just a
couple of starts
two for four
the liner out to left field dwight smith
jr miss plays it it goes under his glove
and to the wall dede's around third
heading for home he'll score the
phillies take a one-nothing lead
just another play you got to think ahead
the phil's will take it no doubt
but dwight smith very unsure of himself
he sends anthony santander to the plate
he doubled back in the first inning
well hit way back is it a fair ball into
the corner
and it's a foul ball i don't know did
that
look at that hit i thought that hit the
fair pole or the foul pole whatever you
want to call it but i guess it didn't
here comes brandon hyder we'll take a
look at it from the angle we had it
looked like to me it hit the foul pole
but if it did that's a good that's good
news
there we go
touch them all
how about that anthony santander
has tied the game up with a solo home
run
for anthony that's his fourth of the
year and guess what his rbi streak
continues six straight games a career
high for him with rbis way up in the air
you see bryce harper chasing it towards
the line and right
there ding you heard it you could almost
hit it like hitting the bell hits the
pole listen ping there it is little mark
i see the mark kind of like in tennis
right yes yes shot of it there yeah now
bryce he walked his first time up
and he bumps it toward third that'll be
a base hit for bryce harper
and the phillies have runners on first
and second that's that was it the third
time he's done that this year second
second time
that one has broken bat looper out to
center it's going to drop it for a hit
hoskins around third heading for home
harper speeding a third it's an rbi
single the phillies retake the lead it's
a 2-1 game
that ball is smoked deep to right field
santander going back it's going to get a
run home harper will tag from third and
the phillies have a 3-1 lead
situational hitting right you get a
runner over around third actually this
time second and third nobody down and
now it's up to chance cisco who struck
out and his first at bat he was call
looking
left field dropping it's in they should
get two home
here comes this
the slide and smith is in and the
orioles score two to tie it up chance
cisco with some clutch two out hitting
serves one into left field and we're
tied at three
runners on the corner one down armstrong
trying to get a ground ball here and
there it is
ruiz the second for one on to first and
the orioles turn two and get out of the
inning how about that sean armstrong
ruiz has grounded out twice once to the
pitcher and then once to his counterpart
gene segura third
ruiz gets a hold of one way back
and it is out of here
into the first row of seats
rio ruiz with his fourth home of the
year and the orioles take a 4-3 lead
he has made a difference since coming
back he's made some outstanding plays
over at third base
he got him yeah
yeah
body was going to first base but phil
gosling
will have to make a turn back and go to
the dugout
phil uh you're out somebody needs to
tell him that he just struck out looking
yeah you're on phil
i've seen guys start to first base but
not get down there and take off their
glove and equipment and then be told hey
orioles trying to grab a run or two to
improve this 4-3 lead yeah they would
love to start put adding some runs
you just get the feeling this game is
not going to stay 4-3 it's way too much
baseball left we talk about turning
points with the armstrong coming and
getting the double play
oh cisco jumps on one way back and it is
gone
so chance cisco with his third rbi of
the game
and his second home of the season that
was a no doubter
that was loud
have a day chance cisco huh
the base hit the left scored two and now
delivers the big home run five to three
orioles we're in the bottom of the
eighth inning here at citizens bank park
phillies with two runners on
and a line drive basin it to right field
segura will score going to second is
dede he had to hold up to make sure the
ball wasn't caught it's another rbi for
nap his second of the night he has three
hits
have a night andrew
that it's a 5-4 game bill's down to
their last out and it's a good one jt
romuto here's the one two
oh
yes sir
a late call jose
cole salser closes it out and gets the
save